[Music]
I thought I heard something it sounded
like Megan if she comes in this room
I'll rip your head right off your neck I
swear to God
I thought about what you said
about
how when something's broken you don't
just throw it away you fix it
so that's what I'm trying to do
but don't come in here Katie it's kind
of a mess on gem is Right Katie I'm all
odds and ends right now I'd really
rather you can see me like this
it sounds like you're fighting we're not
fighting Gemma just dropped me on the
table but I'm okay clumsy Focus oh we
will it's insane
I designed Megan to protect Katie from
feeling lonely
she will recognize you as her primary
user and when you do that you're gonna
pair with her
crazy it's insane right
Megan your goal is to protect Katie from
harm both physical and emotional
[Music]
you don't get to say that
[Music]
very good
what are you doing couldn't sleep
occupational hazard
[Music]
hell is that
you should probably run
don't let anything harm you ever again
I can have I done something to upset you
Gemma I know you think you're maximizing
your objective function oh really
[Music]
laughs
Megan baby doll skill don't be Focus or
we will go
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
do something bad
what's going on
[Music]
what are you I'm Megan
oh we will
[Music]